alright welcome back another edition of
coaching with jen the fantasy copywriter
episode number 11 we ready getting some
props a little different on blab you get
props when you click on the person's
face okay ah so what's up tell me what's
what's the update has been okay so since
we talked last I had developed a Content
calendar and I did pretty good was
sticking with that but one thing I like
made sure that i did was due up one
copywriting video week per our
conversation yeah so I'm pretty proud of
myself for that because I celebrate I
did that ops we're gonna be the cops
there you go yeah and I love it because
that's hilarious these little bubbles
coming up I love it um so yeah so that
was uh that was pretty cool i'm really
glad about that and i have so many more
cup already videos now too and I took
your advice and decided not to like over
sake it and not like bright copy for
each one of them in fact I didn't I
think I'm wrote copy for any of them i
just talked about my feelings of
philosophies on things and the other
thing that's been great which I love is
it now that I have more subscribers
people are asking me questions and make
suggestions and comments on my videos
and so it like gives me ideas for more
stuff more videos so um it's been great
so I've been doing that and I many weeks
I did two videos I think maybe one week
I had three but for the most part of one
copyrighted video a week so and that
content color to really helped the head
it like a scheduled out like what I'm
gonna do and that was it was huge to
have that like calendar doubt and
scheduled and thought ahead of time I
love it and and and they're short you
know like two minutes three minutes you
see the BAM because your other ones were
eight Marilyn yes I want to value but it
took an insane amount of time to put
together right right exactly because it
wasn't just the filming it was the M
editing it was the like riding the copy
and like screenshots of before and
afters and those look like you said
those are valuable and I definitely want
to do some more of those I just um in
order to keep to my goal I just decided
to make it easy so it could it be
multi-part to like that that 10 minute
video that you used to do could that be
52 minute videos yeah i think it
probably could be cuz like there was
like that yeah like that Portland
copy video I did you know I took 10
different websites or maybe was eight I
can't remember even anymore but it was
like a lot of different websites that i
wrote for and I could have just broken
that up an individual a little mini
videos and like continue the series it's
not become a fun idea maybe I should do
that again yeah I mean it's great to
understand the theory behind it right
you're powerful opinion on this topic on
how to write a headline is whatever and
you have your methodology and then you
could have a quick anecdote or example
from your own life or story or like you
know you walked into Whole Foods and you
saw this and it was great or it was
terrible well you can easily follow that
up with something the next week showing
an example of a website if you want to
go deeper into it yeah I think that's a
cool idea I love the idea taking real
world examples like the tweet you had
the other day i love that that was
awesome i love things it was true that I
was like it's condom and that's awesome
oh yeah yeah I remember one oh yeah it
was like a nuts thing about Christmas
and how you can throw away like after
Christmas or something I Cameron Bure I
couldn't even hardly tell it was it
looks like those nuts right yeah yeah
those those I'm eyes at walnuts no
vomiting walnuts it looked like walnuts
in the picture so like the idea was yo
you can take these and decorative in a
bowl for Christmas event throw my sure
cuz mullahs are a pain in the ass to
correct let me tell you my grandma is
you like cracker wall anyway random
changes I like it so with lab you also
we can see you know how many props sweet
get so you're you're destroying me right
now and the props I love it I love it
thanks day feel like I need to talk more
to get more props oh now he's doing it
he's property okay so you have your
content columns are great uh and the the
content that sorry the copy ones have
been consistent and it's great to see
that because you had a stretch there was
all personal or book without anything
about the business for ya um so so how
do you evolve that now because the goal
last time was to have one personal one
copy business-related right for a week
yep so you're close yeah I'm close well
I had the idea of maybe evolving it by
because now that you can do a little
mini videos on Instagram and Twitter um
maybe even just doing like a little you
know 10 second video or whatever however
my second you have on each of those to
say hey check out my new video on so
almost like doing a video to come out
the video that's on YouTube and
experimenting with that you can't what
about getting the other piece consistent
that the personal one or the book one
something you have the blue series the
yeah and the balloon is the fantasy
friday and then I've been doing um the
take a leap on Mondays which I think
would be a really good one to make sure
I continue one of the things I've done
with that is a lot of my mastermind
videos I've used for that which have
been great because they're kind of like
they're sort of business oriented but
they're about like my bit McNee though
turret to like my own personal take on
my business so I've been wondering like
should I continue doing those would take
the leap or should I like focus more on
like um you know something more specific
about what I'm doing to help my business
which is kind of how I sort of
originally presented that series true or
you time together if you see is you fit
like um what was the last one talking
about the favorite book another right
yeah well jerez had for this week is the
which I've filmed already I seven put up
yet so that was the what ways to inject
fun into your day right now right so
yeah I think actually that could be
applicable to particularly for sure and
if you're talking about a book that
could be related you relate to your
business even if it's not a business
lesson even it's a personal life lesson
that you like why do you like this book
because it give you confidence and then
you can tie that into my business
business yeah with a good story yeah I
like it okay yes I will take it to the
next level and for sure do a take the
leap video every week and I still want
to do penis you Friday I'm kind of I've
been sort of doing every other week with
its due friday so i think that's kind of
good to you know keep that bri other
friday but for sure do take the leap i
love it so along those lines can you
batch them together I can
I can eat like even as far as filming
them all on the same day yeah yeah I
mean now that I've sort of established
my content calendar it's a lot easier to
do that because I determined ahead of
time what I'm gonna do so it's just a
matter of one of the things obviously
that's because i'm a newbie i'm still
learning how to you know what am i
trying to stay here do it quickly and
smoothly and you know so there are days
like I've planned on doing three videos
and I only did one because it like took
me longer than I thought right so um a
lot I guess yeah I think a lot of it is
that there's a lot of setup time to get
ready both in terms of like the camera
and the gear and we know you do I pup
but also eye makeup and clothes and
getting ready I mean doing the hair and
and then third is just the mindset of
being ready to like I'm writing in my
book I don't want to talk to anybody
it's like all right no I get it don't
talk to me I want to do my thing in my
zone but when I when I finish doing one
video I can I'm right already in that
zone easy to go into another video in
another video just give me another topic
go let's go let's do more I knew Evan
I'm all set up right but he takes a
little bit of mental effort to get ready
for it the first time um I great I'd
remember me it's like a full-on setup
because i have a backdrop that i put up
and then I like I mean you know I'm kind
of laughing cuz my setup is kind of like
we she's like I literally have us
rolling dishwasher that I role in that I
like set up my camera on which I'm
changing my one of my goals was next
month is sick you know get it like a
tripod you know attachment for my iphone
and some other things but in the
meantime for now it's like furniture
like it's put in place and hilarious so
you're right like it's a lot of time
setting that up so it does make sense to
do them all ones yeah you could probably
you could probably bang those out and
and have two or three videos a week
because they're not they're not one that
long look you're not talking fantasy
Friday's two minutes under two minutes
it's not right like valuable but not a
an insane amount of war
put together oh yeah I think you just
put them all in the same day what when
is it is it still sunday or one is your
video recording day I've been doing on
Tuesdays and then I moved to tuesdays i
originally wanted to do it on my face
but it just it's turned out to be
Tuesday's the better day okay yeah try
it yeah i mean at least the two if not
the three okay okay yeah I think it's a
great idea I mean there was this one
time with Jason one time I like film
like 10 videos or something in one day
and like what I wanted to Seattle with
you like you had a mom I'm in get easily
to have everything prepared ahead of
time you know you can just whip them out
we did like what seven videos in an hour
or something like that since yeah with
you we just have to learn with the
camera I mean that's cool too yeah a
unit using a min oh right it's like even
know I'd never eaten go right right and
so here at least you're talking about
you know fantasy friday you're talking
with something that boat that's
meaningful to you that you like and why
all this stuff you have the copy 12 you
have you have expertise you've thought
about this if you haven't likes
word-for-word know what you're going to
say you thought about and have an idea
yeah so yeah i like it i like the idea
of doing two or three on the same day i
like you got the consistency on the
business one now i'd love to see the
consistent let's see on on the other one
okay okay i love jose no has to make
sure that our props are equal like is is
there to make sure that the other side
goes up and the cno's like the same
number and inside until somebody
disrupts the force right and he's gonna
come back and make it right again okay
ok so here that's running with a
question this is a content creation
bring you value personally is it
rewarding is it does it feel worthwhile
absolutely for me um i love it i think
it's great to I don't know I love being
able to talk about it and I think it's
for personally I think it's also helps
clarify things for me so that what I'm
out talking to customers I am making
more sense to and also i use a lot of
this is my personal life in fact so last
weekend I had a fundraiser for my dance
group that i'm a part of and one of the
things that we did was a cakewalk and so
we all baked a cake and then you know
like each one of the the dancers baked a
cake and then we know auction it off at
the cake block right and so I was like
hey this is grab beneath me to look at
copywriting so I took pictures of all
the cakes and I'm a little signs rich of
the cakes and I was super fun and action
was kind of funny i tried to facebook it
and I totally messed up and posted it on
our personal soul cages the same of are
going to be a scripted soul and so I
kind of messed up I didn't like properly
promote it like I should have so be more
prepared but that's my point is that i
can use them the stuff i do in personal
life for business as well and it helps
me you know cross promotes helps me in
both personal and it work cool and then
so you mentioned you getting some
comments and subscribers and feedback
now starting on the channel yeah what
what kind of feedback are you getting
it's mostly positive i think a lot of
people just want to know more about
something i'm talking about in depth
they want to know about more of my
process they want to know more about
fantasy I'm still amazed by people who
don't fantasize and they're like how do
you thin Assize I'm like oh I don't
understand I don't understand the
question it hurts my head yeah but um
but no they're great questions questions
I've never even think about but I think
the cool thing about the videos is they
really help people understand i'm
talking about what's fantasy because i
think people sometimes disco power
fantasy and copyright and related like I
don't get it and i think the videos help
me communicate that and it helps them
understand it so while the comments and
questions are around that and around you
know get an advice collaborate in which
are great it's great because it gives me
more content to talk about and then so
can you turn those into videos yeah yeah
which I have done I
in fact I have like three more videos of
from past questions and comments that
are slated that I'm going to be doing in
the next couple weeks so um I gotta
catch up now oh look like my world
alright alright yeah guess so many
questions or comments like you don't
even have to think about anymore the
content right you just pull what they
say there's there is no more thinking
it's all requests that's all requests um
cool now like taking it back and looking
about your business um can these be
things that you show some of them to
prospective clients there any of them is
this only like helping people who want
to learn copy or would would flock
potential clients of yours be watching
these and getting value from the two
yeah I think they could I could probably
be a little bit more strategic about the
videos that produce and and think about
okay what would be a great video that i
can email to somebody who is a prospect
right so yeah i probably could be a
little bit more strategic about that but
i definitely think that they there are
some that I definitely think I could use
and I have in the past like there's a
storytelling selling one and actually
how about one of my my front page of my
website but I actually want to update
that I'd make it a little bit more
relevant to someone who's like new to my
website so might be another great one I
can do for the website in when I get
email out to people that's a great idea
even the topics as you get as you get
better like every video you get better
more comfortable more practice right
what a pair like last week's compared to
it the first one I remember my first one
still be actually really good like
compared to my first one I've managed
and it's a rock star um hey but like you
may find yourself one and update that
video a number of times uh right J reyez
gives you all the talk to mike j reyez
okay the prop yeah yeah props you gotta
do damage or make my day
phalaris a little bit competing for
probs yeah my last black we had like it
was it was an hour long we're like
20,000 props or something was crazy um
yeah it's an interesting platform uh yes
you may find it what's that as I'm
digging this platform so far it's fun
cool yeah um so think about it be good
to think of what videos you can put on
your website so people who are visiting
get a better sense of what you're doing
that is it ties into your channel and
still is educational but then also
provides a high-level overview uh-huh
and that that may need to be updated
like every six months every three months
like as you get better you may be the
same story that you tell but you're not
better at your my energetic maybe you
use fantasy more and it you know it's
every time you tell the story you get
better at telling that story you find
more is nuances how you word it the
intonation you just get better every
time alright so that might be a cool
thing to put on and also if you're
talking about I don't if you have a page
on your site that talks about your
process and your your your as seven
steps or whatever it is I don't but that
may good idea it'd be good to have a
video on each one of them too uh huh uh
from a content strategy on the website
as well as on the YouTube channel it
would be great to know here are my seven
steps and here's what each of the mean
like you do a video on each this is this
is generally not one is headline right
one is call to action so three minutes
on what a good call to action isn't
you've done you've done yeah call to
action you've done headline I know those
two but there's others that I don't
remember if you did a quick video on
each one of them wound up on your
landing page and then also what you do
future videos on YouTube channel you can
reference it back and put a card or an
annotation oh yeah it's a great idea
today we're going to go deeper on called
action you can watch main show video
with the link above and then you go
diving
with an example right it unburied I have
unburying content because there's so
much content people don't go back on the
channel to find those right um yeah you
have so much youtube content what do you
think about and this doesn't have
actually tossed around doing before
instead of putting like outlets you know
like there's seven or eight things that
are like part of my process first sales
page what what if I'd like to the video
series with the video on each one but
then how they kind of an overview on my
website that how do way to capture leads
and then they have access to the videos
you know for free if they if they saw
Nina give me their email because I don't
have any really way right now to capture
em I'm gonna do but it's real general
it's like encouraging people to share
their fantasy with me or people will
contact me if they're interesting
copyright and they'll just send it
through that form um but other than that
there's no real web page setup yeah
you'll probably have to markets this I
just talked with on the last Blood the
guys who will respect you and pay you
for the bigger projects are are usually
unlikely to go through a newsletter
filter process think base they may
because you're not dealing with massive
clients but I think of you know for my
big deals when i sell the microsoft or
dell or any of these companies they
never they didn't find me through my
newsletter and then they got dripped
content and then right they have a need
they're like okay who's who's talking
about entrepreneurship okay Oh Evan okay
let's let's bring them on and get a call
going like they have a need they want to
solve it I'm talking for those clients
that's it's consistently putting out
content so that when they are searching
for copywriters your name comes up or if
they ask their friends they oh this
person you got to go talk to them oh and
it's just like sheer volume of content
plus quality stuff and so like any more
you produce the more you grow your
catalog and
better you get at doing this the more
likely you're going to get clients
finding you and wanted to do some kind
of deal together the newsletter strategy
can work it's usually it's usually at
the lower end it's usually like uh it's
usually like as guys who don't have an
immediate need if they hadn't reckoned
they had a budget they would hire you so
as people right media need or they don't
have budget right or they want to do it
themselves and I just kind of want
advice on how to do it invitation so
like I don't know if that's a strategy
that you want to pursue like if you are
then creating if your longer-term vision
was I want to create a copywriting
course I want to teach people how to be
great copywriters inject financing to
what they're doing have a book to sell
or udemy online course or whatever it is
oh that's definitely something that you
should pursue right like my business is
I do the I do the high-end clients and I
do the masses right like right your
ginger um so I don't know where you want
to take you with your business like I've
never would never talked about that
angle i don't--that's on your radar
that's the biggest or not or if it's
just I want to work with clients um yeah
I think it's of interest like long term
for sure yeah i think it is and i also
think to there's something to a small
business owner that might like think
they want to write copy themselves right
now and then once they started like I
don't want to do this or they don't like
it or it's like a temporary solution
until they can grow their business more
and then they might hire a copywriter so
I can see that being helpful with the
newsletter strategy getting cooperating
tips unit I mean until they can grow
more I don't know though I mean I think
you're right though I think most people
to have contacted me they like they have
immediate need they saw YouTube video or
they read my beam out one of my blog
posts or they just heard about me
somehow for a friend and they're like I
knew copywriting I want to hire you yeah
it's really hard to grow with your
client
um sometimes it happens and it can but
it's only select few like it's hard to
have it as a bankable strategy to say
like okay I'm going to go out and get
all these startups and then I'm going to
work with them and give them copy
writing tips and in the future when they
grow they're going to be able to afford
to hire me most of them won't grow right
like you got to be super selective on
who you work with because most of them
won't grow and the curse of
entrepreneurship of selling the
entrepreneurs is they don't have budgets
right and you want your words right look
and it is you like you have a you've
attachment and they're on a good mission
and you love what they're doing and
maybe a portion of what you do is oh I
mean this is who I work with constantly
I face that battle to where like I can
only I only have so many hours in the
day I solve it through mass content like
this right like well creating videos
where people can tune in and ask
questions and learn so they may not get
access to me one-on-one but they can
learn from osmosis and by hanging around
and watching the videos um you know so
it's thinking longer term is your goal
to be a a personality and to have a mass
following like you want a mass following
or do you want a niche following um you
know if you want to write a book for
example right like you're damn right way
if you book then part of that is I need
to follow it like who's gonna buy the
book because that you want to get a
publisher on board they want uh to see
that like now it's all about can this
author sell the book because we don't
know how to sell books it's all about
the author um so having a big audience
makes a big difference there uh and if
that's the goal to just like I'm going
down on this tangent ya know it's great
is the audience that you're building on
your channel relevant to the audience
would buy your book right because if
you're giving copy writing tips that's a
different audience and the people who
are going to want to buy a book about
people doing magical things with their
hands
right right some people will overlap
just because I love gin I love you know
I went and wrote a book on
entrepreneurship it has a high
likelihood to sell to my audience right
if I write a book about salsa dancing
which I know a lot about how many of my
audience would buy it it's just it's a
disconnect right right if that was the
goal i would start building a salsa
audience of people who love that and
want to learn about that all right so
interesting it so would you recommend
then if I because that's one thing I do
want to start doing is going back to
doing more of my book fantasy videos I
mean I have it on a separate playlist
but would you recommend out maybe a
whole new channel for that yeah so I
honestly i would say it depends on where
you are uh in your life and how much you
can afford the experiment um you look at
zenos comment there Zeno's a hardcore
fan okay awesome i love it Zeno's
American man he was on he's on on two
sessions today he come in son almost
every video it loves and stuff right and
if he asked me a question you know he
has my attention I would answer it no
problem I would not buy a book of us to
be on his sorry I'm right like yeah hes
a hardcore fan i have a lot of clout
with him you know and he would not buy
that book right oh so I mean some people
would just destroy but you know it's uh
it's a hard sorry it's a hard hard
market to build up so like if you had
extra time as an example oh then you
could start on these parallel paths and
like we're talking about now do we have
enough time with my videos a week on my
regular channel now I got to do a new
channel do this um I think there can be
a little bit of overlap I'm like I
talked about salsa dancing from a
business contacts I'm right on my
business channel and I'll share stories
about hiring the team when working with
this company and whatever right I it's
always the mighty two channels on
reflection of what I do and who I am
so sauce is now a big part of it I bring
into the channel but I don't have how to
dance sauce I think I have like one
video on there about that the rest is
just business context if you only wrote
south so you can go to the salsa channel
and learn about that I like that there
is some bleed or does it give greater
context understanding but if I started
posting half of my videos salsa on my
youtube channel and half of them
business I would lose everybody like I
don't get more salsa and business fans
which is a this audience for that but
it's a lot smaller so it feels like a
place where would be another channel in
their channel but I worry about your
time and I want you to make your
copywriting business a success and get
the clients that you're looking for in
need I maybe build if you're me I
probably get it to the point where I
could afford to build a bit of a team on
the YouTube channel especially take the
editing my way yes so if you could just
show up on the Monday or Tuesday with
your washing machine or maybe a 45 you
know have you try pod you have your
setup you have an editor he's not a full
time I don't just somebody to do yeah um
then that frees up your time to then do
other things that you're great at and
could be starting this new YouTube
channel until then and you have to do
what's right I just feel like it's just
trying to water too many clients and
then nothing gets really watered and
everything kind of just doesn't grow um
yeah I told you mean I don't miss for
myself too thin I also wonder too it's
kind of almost opposite if your business
in that though that like I feel like my
copyright is more niche and the book is
more of a mass interest maybe I don't
know but I could be wrong like maybe
maybe I got that off and and maybe and I
you're right I kind of dude some overlap
like I talked about how writing for a
book can be similar to writing for copy
but it is I mean you're right i think
people who are just my cover and are
going to be either potential comp like
want to be copywriters or business
owners
who may want to hire me or write their
own copy so it is different for sure
totally different content yeah I don't
honestly know like that the group that
you left out is is corporate like I
don't that may be your biggest market of
all not targeting obviously not [ __ ]
copywriters granite mmm business owners
it's a select group would be willing to
spend on a copywriter um but it be I
think corporate like people running
campaigns who need something different
they're not getting results like you
walked in i forget the store you walked
into when you analyze their signs and
thought they were terrible yeah that
company should be the one hiring you so
you're dealing with like a marketing vp
of marketing or communications oh I
think that's my much better angle and
then so that's the audience then does
your content speak to them now as much
as I love entrepreneurs like I'm the
entrepreneur guy I don't think you're
going to get the lifestyle and the
growth that you want trying to sell
high-end services to entrepreneurs who
may love it and appreciate you to death
but can't afford it right well I think
there's there's like there's some other
between corporate and like a small
business owner I feel like there's that
like I just said Jay rises question to
work with bold leaders Portland style
absolutely i love to work with bold
leaders and I feel like they're there
are businesses out there that have a you
know like they're not small and I might
be like the local business owner in
Portland they're not like a huge
corporate client per se but there
because I feel like a lot of what a lot
of corporate clients do is they hire
agencies that means I've been working
with the agency you know it's some kind
of reduced rate because they have all
these access to co-operators and that
you know I think having a relationship
with someone has a bold leader you know
like yourself for example right who's
willing to pay for a copywriter it's not
necessarily a small business owner but
you're right that's it that's a really
good thing I really should have down
right who's my target calling it and who
should I go after and that will help
determine what I'm do with my channel I
like as you talked about me being a bold
leader the Sun like came through the win
I'm on it up then I'm feeling problem
first all right I like it um yeah it you
know still thinking about someone who
has a team and somebody who is doing
bold things it just may not always be
the entrepreneur it may be a politician
it maybe it maybe somebody who is at a
company I they may be tired of their
agencies like i displace agencies and
when I work with them it's not at the
discounted rate you know like it's right
why are you different so different than
these guys that that are not producing
the results okay well that's the key so
um yeah and they're right and agencies
might be willing to pay more too because
they're working a client budget such as
pence on yeah like you said I do feel
like why I'm different they like my work
if they think it's warranted pay more
money for right um yeah I just yeah
coming from the agency I worked for a
couple different agencies and I kind of
know sometimes how they think and they
like to sometimes you know hire someone
who in paying out a lot of money so they
can then keep a lot of that profit when
I pass on the cost of client right so
it's establishing good relationship
dress up the client if I can yeah I have
a mixed relationship with agencies I
don't want to throw them all under the
bus yeah I told ya the same thing with
brands like most brands that want to
work with me I we can't work together
like they're the witches don't align
they just want me to pitch their stuff
when I haven't even used it or know it
or care about it and they're very
transactional and so I end up turning
away a lot of deals that I could make
you know some good money with but just
it's not in the long-term best interest
and they won't get the results they're
looking for either um I think when
people clearly understand your
difference then they're coming to you
with a specific goal so you're not just
let's get a copywriter right let's get
somebody to write an article about small
business tons of people could write that
right you know that's not me like if you
don't have
a series of 42 doing this and a budget
I'm not the guy to work with right and I
love that yes it's like yeah like the
equivalent right you just tons of
copywriters great that you can't be just
any copywriter and if you are really
clear about that and your difference and
people how I mark it is i'm not really
the salesperson I'm not the guy knocking
on doors and saying hey buy my stuff or
born in networking of answering that
it's all it's through marketing I'm much
more Wow where'd you go shoot i don't
know if i'm not on your gun can you see
me okay what happened to him i'm still
here but what he was saying was wrong
with what Jason said was do these guys
use fantasy effectively you're right i
mean like that's what i need to promote
as my fantasy abilities and I can't okay
it's evidence in charge of this blab
what do i do I don't know what to do ah
yes give props mmm and if i should start
over we should start a new blob I guess
we should probably wrap it up soon
anyway right Jason stop it on hey day
what's up your me again there we go yo
yo are you with Evan right now hell no
okay Yuri Oh like
that's awesome you popped on anything
you can pop on and Lance escamole drug
that is cool I think ever had to click
yes though okay gotcha oh yeah I think
you're right because i read about lab
all right I've been this is I I can't
see J reyez either but feel like this
session is rocking but let's get it back
on track uh-un Evan we're talking about
agencies and brands and targets so you
want to elaborate yeah well I just think
he had a good point which is you know he
was talking about like basically I have
something that somebody else doesn't and
that's why they would hire me yeah and
what I'm gonna pay more because they're
looking for something that I have which
is famous Steve right so I need to UM do
better job communicating that and so
that people will hire me for that think
that I have it nobody else has yeah so
what it's not what are some good ways
you can clarify that for people um I
could do that through my youtube channel
alter my website better I could do it um
you know everything that i do i feel
like i do a decent job with social media
but I can you know I can do better job I
website that for sure like mine mo said
his work big time uh Zeno is saying F
and where'd you go I miss you so it's
like being it's been forever that you
didn't feel like taking a shower
guardian I know I totally does that's
almost a wrap hey put your poet no no it
if you have a kid I found going to Z no
I don't know if you want to remake the
remake the video evident like it says
shows he's talking there's some kind of
a pulse I know it's like boo boo boo I
don't know if I don't know what it is
magically magic of lab all right well
what time is it sessions over any luck
for him yeah he was in the engine anyway
so we saved it that was messed up I
don't know what happened there I don't
need their help by Jay thanks for it
thanks for asking that saves its ranting
about agencies and then then I got
kicked off its very interesting
um yeah so I feel like J reyez you know
added some value there um but I think
it's with any with any agency your
clients there's a lot of wrong people
and I think we try to if you just sit in
the box of copywriter you're gonna get a
lot of wrong people who don't want you
and just is a commodity service you know
like just yeah I get some generic thing
that's not me right you type in
copyright I can get somebody who's you
know in high school closings of a
copywriter who doesn't have an
experience and you know I so like it's
understanding your point of difference
in making that clear and everything
you're doing and I think I think that
maybe add some clarity to the channel
and your website too is if the audience
is going to be how are you define it if
it's if it's bold leaders or I don't
think it has to be living at the
Portland that could be your onto now and
it's you know I agree to meet them and
lesson do unless that's what you do you
have to meet them but defining who you
want to work with and then even if you
don't know them yet right like then when
you're creating your content you're
imagining that this ideal person is
watching it and even if it's not be a
sales pitch like okay and call me now
I'm Jen the fantasy corporator right but
if the intention is there to meet that
audience then that'll come through in
the videos and you'll create the content
that will be all relevant valuable for
them where if you just stay in the small
business solopreneur you know or cop
behind or kind of zone then yeah I think
you've got a really great point it's
what it's funny but this came up because
I actually got a conversation recently
about this because they were like famous
ease way to niche like people don't
understand it like they're just not
gonna you know you should have like a
general like ah you know I'm a
copywriter and I was like no like less
exactly the opposite of what i should do
i should like you know maybe just better
to find what the agency is for people
but but i mean yeah i could just stand
for something
your dad then you're not i'm not going
to attract the right people to work with
me yeah and also if you look at the
examples that you use right if you you
know if you look at I remember you'd a
woman a coaching woman website or
whatever right then who's gonna like
that it's gonna be other coaching women
right right which is not who you want to
work with so if you're in your examples
and your I don't like something they'll
be relevant to me as an ideal person
however high points then like if you if
you politics just as an example not that
I'm advocating it all right and talking
about how politicians should be using
fantasy in their speeches and you broke
them for the next 20 videos is breaking
down political speeches and and
campaigns and tactics who's going to
subscribe to your channel it's going to
be people interested in politics and how
to use communication effectively your
next gig might be writing a speech for
politician and so you know that doesn't
have to be your angle but think about
who your ideal client is and maybe you
haven't fully work that out but you
think over they are then you create
content for them even the intention the
intention is for them they will start to
come right absolutely are people that
are similar to them I love it great
suggestion all right well there we go
all right love it great glass come back
on a rapid asset that's all so we made
it thank you for this awesome session
have a great end of the year you taste
the next time we'll connect on this will
be in January yeah 2016 see you next
year okay i'm sure i'll talk too far
thank you for sure ok cool thanks james
thanks everybody from happening hi
everybody thank you